hello everyone my name is Fellini I'm
assistant professor at Delft University
of Technology and what it says on the
program is that I'll do to talk how to
teach programming and other things but
that is fake news I have changed my mind
and therefore I have declared the
program to be erroneous wrong this is
not the talk I'm going to give I am
going to give a new talk because I did
this talk already twice last week so I
was like I'm not sure I can bring the
right energy to do that talk again so I
compile the new talk today if you're
really really were looking forward to
how to teach programming and other
things we can just skip right to the end
the ends and you can leave it's ok you
can leave you can go to my website and
there's a video of this talk online so
if you really want to see it this is
your chance to just leave say take your
laptop and look at the talk I was going
to give no takers ok fair enough
so what I am going to talk about today
is this thing that I call code phonology
which means how do people speak code how
did a year code how the source code
sound if you read it love but before I'm
going to talk about that I am going to
give you a little bit of a backstory
into how I got into this research topic
and just to confuse people that have
seen my other talks the first few
minutes of this talk will actually be
the same as the first part of how did
these programming and other things but
don't worry after a few minutes it will
diverge so to keep you awake I have some
audience participation
who knows who set this everyone should
learn how to program
who said this every programmer ever you
someone who's seen my talk so every
programmer ever I we all love
programming so many people say
programming it's the best everyone
should learn how to program we all say
this however it leads to an interesting
question because if we apparently
believe that everyone should program
what is programming what do we mean if
we say everyone should learn programming
what is the skill level what is a
programming language what do we
what do we even teach them and you might
think that what is programming is a
super easy question that's actually a
pretty hard question if you ask 10
people what is programming probably you
gets 10 different answers and if we
would ask people what programming is we
would probably ask people like us like
other programmers and we programmers we
might not be the best people to answer
this question and that's maybe best
explained by this story about three fish
in the sea there swimming maybe you know
the story and the big fish says hey
folks how's the water so he asked the
two small fishies how's the water and
the two small fish they say what's water
fish don't know what water is because
the only thing they've ever been in is
water so for them water is synonymous
with everything with the world with the
universe and we're programmers we're a
little bit like that the only water we
know is programming most people program
not only as their profession but also as
a hobby lots of people have friends that
are also programmers so we're in this
water of programming all the time and
maybe that makes us not the best people
to decide what programming is and also
what isn't programming because if we say
this is programming that also means some
other things aren't programming and to
really understand my perspective on what
is and what isn't programming let me
take you back to the year 2008 when I
started my PhD project so I moved from
Eindhoven this is in the tiny country of
the Netherlands to Delft it's a really
small move it's like a hundred
kilometres but for someone from a tiny
country that's a big move so I went to
to Delft the University where I still
work today
and I've started a PhD project and the
research question for this piece the
project the research question that my
supervisor had in mind was was less
research DSL a domain-specific language
for finance so what we envisioned was a
programming language a little bit like
COBOL in which end-user programmers
normal people could express their
business rules and therefore they would
rely less on programmers to make
software they could make their own
software which is nice so the first
thing
I did in my PhD projects as I did an
internship at a Dutch insurance company
to figure out what are people doing in
finance what would be the keywords and
the things that we need to go in such a
domain-specific language and what they
learn me in university I'm not sure if
this is still true if they still teach
this to kids at university but I just
had my master's degree and they sort of
said this is how the world looks like
you have users and then there's a wall
and then there are programmers they are
different species they sometimes
communicate a little bit but these types
of people have nothing to do with each
other and the programmers program and
users use that's it that's how the world
looks like at least this is my 20 year
old naive view this is how things go
people need stuff and the programmers
make it this illusion was quickly
shattered when I started this internship
at this insurance company because it
turned out everyone was programming the
programmers were programming and also
the normal people were programming
however it wasn't that they were
programming in a traditional textual
language as me and my supervisor and
visions no they were programming in
spreadsheets those normal people they
could program they didn't really need
the programmers at all they were pretty
well equipped with spreadsheets that
they use for financial modeling and risk
assessments they were they were doing
fine really
so I went back to my supervisor as a
friends they don't need it because our
finance they have an ESL finance it's
cool Excel it's a pretty good thing
we're never going to be able in a
four-year PD project or however long we
work on this to be able to come up with
something that is going to outperform
spreadsheets for what those people mean
so the model of my face the dissertation
became spreadsheets are codes and
they're not just code spreadsheets are
really and I say this without any irony
spreadsheets are the best programming
language that has ever existed in the
history of programming spreadsheets are
such a good programming language people
don't know that their programming
imagine doing Java by accident imagine
this conversation hey Frank what are you
doing well I opened up Eclipse it was
installed on my laptop and it was so
intuitive I just jumped right into it
and now I built this risk assessment
model no one ever but it's funny how
weird that sounds but for spreadsheets
it's solely true
they are so intuitive that people just
open it up and figure out what to do
they know what to do and they can teach
you to do themselves and be pretty
proficient so it's it's really an
amazing programming language it's not
just a programming language it has all
the buzzwords so maybe you never thought
of it like this but spreadsheets are
functional programming a formula and a
spreadsheet can only take inputs from
other cells in the spreadsheet and
calculate the results based on that so
it's a formula in a Cell cannot change
other cells so it's pure pure functional
programming inside the factory it's not
just functional it's also reactive if
you update a cell in the spreadsheet
only a part of the spreadsheet is
recalculated that depends on this cell
so spreadsheets are reactive pure
functional programming and yet 750
million people can use it eat that
Haskell so spreadsheets are code this is
my story it was a summary of my my
teases and I went to all these
conferences around the world to talk
about that and it also gave me my teases
my dissertation so that was a happy
story I did all this research on
spreadsheets and I graduated hooray
however that's only part of the story in
a previous version I did of this talk
someone said that this talk was just
Felina doing therapy with an audience
true it's true so this part about all
the research I did it's definitely true
but it's only the part of the story of
the brain and there's also the part of
the story of the heart like how was I
feeling while I was doing this so I went
to all these conferences just like this
where I like speaking I was like hello
hello people spreadsheets are code have
your spreadsheets are codes think cool
and people be like yeah it's not real
programming wait wait hold on a second
but it is functional and it's reactive
and everyone can use it and it's not
real programming and this you know it
went on and on and after a while it's
just it really drags you down I mean we
could laugh about it now but it's really
tiring if people keep saying what you're
doing is not real programming like
there's some sort of law there's some
sort of rule that this is programming
and that's no programming and you're in
the wrong side of programming and I
don't know if there are people that data
PhD in the audience but especially for
your teachers work the topic and you
sort of merge into one thing and if
people don't think your topic is very
serious it's really really hurtful and
yeah I broke my heart after a while I
just I really didn't want to work on it
anymore I didn't want to talk about it
anymore it's like I give up and I really
thought at this point that this is the
normal way that people interact with
each other that's if you're just part of
a professional community people will
on your work and they will hate
whatever you do I thought that was
normal
well it's not funny actually so it was
only until later like 2015 when I
realized that other people in other
communities are not to each other
so I also very much like running and
after a while I went to races and now I
joined a running group and everyone is
nice to each other so I have friends
that are twice as quick runners as I am
but they don't say that I'm not a real
runner they're like AHA let's go to a
race together they just wait an hour
until I fall so finished but they don't
make jokes about that and coming from
programming it's just amazing no one
this is each other's ability or tools
everyone's just we love running runners
are terrible that way we are more
evangelistic than Jehovah's Witnesses if
I see you jogging through the bus I'll
be like oh you're like running do you
want to go to race together we wanted
everyone to run we would never say
you're not a real runner for using the
wrong shoes or using the wrong training
schedule and it's awesome and it's not
just running I'm also a knitter and I
didn't knit for a while I I needed a lot
when I was a teenager and I
back to knitting after a few years and I
went to meet up with old-fashioned
straight needles that you know my mother
and my grandmother use these things but
apparently they're not in fashion
anymore everyone now uses circular
needles I didn't know so I go to this
Meetup everyone has different needles
I'm like they're going to say
you're not a real knitter and I will cry
again no no no but it wasn't anything
like that they were like oh you still
have those old needles you know we used
to have those needles it's fine we can
teach you
no one said oh your old needles they
have security vulnerabilities you can't
use them anymore
it was so welcoming and and there's so
many welcoming communities and then if
you look back our programming it's
really like what are we doing to each
other
why are we so mean why are we making
this division between programming and
real programming and not real
programming it's it's weird we should be
like basically any other community
except for program anyway going back to
2012 I was not very happy I didn't want
to work on my research anymore but I
just accepted a professorship at tu
delft so I had to do research because I
told my hiring committee lies like I
told you about the talk I was going to
give I said no I'm going to do lots of
spreadsheet stuff because I'm really
excited because I mean it was what gave
me my PhD and I didn't have any other
ideas so I was stuck in this position I
was supposed to show how good of a
researcher I was and I didn't want any
spreadsheets anymore and I also I was
sad so it might it wasn't a great time
however by total coincidence true people
I knew I got in touch with people that
needed a programming teacher at a local
community center on Saturdays and they
said we have some kids they want to
learn programming and we need a teacher
so like I could probably do that and
initially it really wasn't my intention
to turn those kids into research objects
it was really my intention to do
something fun and useful on Saturdays
but I I got intrigued in hey if we want
to teach kids programming how do we do
that what what is the
we teach programming and ultimately it
became my main line of research so
everything was fine in yet I started
teaching there and this the really
interesting thing happened when I
started teaching I think that's true for
most people my age is that if we think
back of how we learn programming it's
like this so I'm thinking of myself as
ten year olds we had a computer and I
was like by myself I had some books from
the library basic book if you tell this
to eighteen year olds now they think
you're a hundred years old I had paper
books that I got from the library then I
took them to my home and then I typed
all the letters from the book into the
computer how did you know it was correct
miss you had no internets we just kept
trying and trying and trying and this is
I mean it's a great story I love telling
people I told myself programming when I
was ten but the fact that this is how
many of us remember how we learned
programming it really impacts how we see
programming education because notice
there's no teacher in this story so if I
think back of what is a programming
lesson the only frame I have and I think
this is true for the broader programming
community is I was by myself and I had a
book so we don't have a collective image
of how to teach programming because most
of us were never in a programming class
until we were in university and then we
were like yeah we know these things
because we've been doing it for a decade
and this is interesting because if you
think of other things that you learn
like you learn to write or you learn to
read or you learn math or you learned
even to ride a bike you have this memory
of your parents took you to the park and
you have a frame of reference for how
programming how biking education looks
like or writing education we have no
collective memory of how programming
education looks like and that is maybe
maybe it's an opportunity because we can
figure it out but because we don't
really talk about this a lot it sort of
turns into accidentally recreating your
own programming history at least that
was that was the case for me so how I
thought I
should teach them it's like okay they
can figure out everything because
they're like me obviously every children
child is like me so they can figure out
everything we just focus on the hard
part's so I just have to explain them
mutability and in out parameters but all
the rest all the details they will
figure it out because I was like that
but clearly not all kids are like the
people that can teach themselves
programming so many of my programming
lessons and also if you examine
materials of people that are teaching
are very much about concepts so I want
to teach kids about repetition I tell
them a loop is repetition this is the
programming concept the conceptual stuff
and when we don't talk about this yeah
it really matters whether semicolon goes
or to colon or the brackets we then do
not talk about syntax that much because
we don't learned it from books and
that's the easy stuff and the compiler
or the interpreter will tell you let's
talk about the concepts but it was
pretty hard so it was really hard to get
kids to do stuff and I observe them and
also this is what you observe also in
university level students really
struggling with syntax not knowing where
my bracket goes and you have this whole
plan in mind so I'm going to calculate
all the prime numbers and I have a plan
and then the compiler says no the
bracket is wrong and your whole plan is
going because all your entries goes into
syntax hmm why is it so hard I should
read some research about programming
syntax so there's this amazing person
that you should all like look him up on
the internet he's called Andre estatic
he's cool he did actual experiments into
how people read programming languages so
he tried it with novices he gave them
different programming languages and he
started to actually met measure what
works so we had about a hundred
University level student novices in
programming and he told them programming
in different programming languages so he
gave them exercises in Java Perl Python
and Ruby say traditional programming
language and in addition to those four
languages he also included two other
programming languages he designs
quorum is a programming language he
designed to be as good as user-friendly
as possible but he also included random
Oh it is what you think it is it is a
programming language which randomly
generated keywords they make no sense so
you give a hundred students these six
programming language languages and you
see where do they do better so clearly
ren-dono didn't do great but it did
better than Java and Perl forum poisonin
Ruby did better and I ran Domo so let me
put that on the slide for you so you can
all really see it novice programmers do
better in a randomly generated
programming language than they do in
Java Pro this is how bad we are at
inventing programming languages I mean
unlike with the real program it's funny
it's also very sad this is where we are
as an industry and this this work is not
from the 80s this work is from 2012 when
for the first time someone this amazing
person thought hey maybe it's a super
good idea if we actually check what
people get from our programming
languages but that's where we are so
lots of work to do that's a good news
the story here is that syntax is not
intuitive it's not this thing that
people can just pick up and then they
will quickly be able to do conceptual
stuff as I said it's true for many of
the people that are here now but that
doesn't mean it's good we've all been
Stockholm Syndrome by how bad our
programming languages are it's not that
they're intuitive we've just learned how
to work with it because there was no
YouTube when I was 10 year old so I had
this basic book to entertain me it's no
because it's intuitive and good so we
can't assume that kids will or even
adults will just pick it up because it
makes so much sense it makes very little
sense so this is the part of the Watts
I was interested okay I should somehow
spends effort on teaching kids
syntax that's what I need to do but they
don't really knew how to do it how do
you practice syntax in a good way how do
I get them to remember where where does
the semicolon go where does a bracket go
how do I do that how how was the
question and then I would I met this
other amazing person this is because I
hang out at conferences all the time
where are lots of amazing people hang
out so another amazing person and
Alexandra West
she was actually together with her
partner that is a software developer so
she came to the conference as a plus-one
so she's not just an amazing person
she's an amazing person with an art
degree and we were at this conference in
Paris together sitting outside in a
sunny sunny night in paris and we
started talking about what what is art
like it's like Oh tell me about your art
degree and what do you do and of course
I frame everything because I'm a memo in
the water of programming everything in
terms of programming so we started to
talking about what would happen if we
would view source code as artworks if we
would do review of a code review like
art criticism I mean you hang it on the
wall you look at it I mean there were
really interesting perspectives in this
part of the story where you would just
print out your source code you would
just look at it for a while and you just
this this is apparently how people
review art or create criticized art you
look at it now you do something else
you go back you let it sink in a bit you
ask yourself what does this make me
remember we started thinking why don't
we do it as for code just look at it for
a bed do something else how does this
make me feel it's interesting so that in
itself I mean that could be a whole
other talk but I also started thinking
what would happen if we would create
code as we would create artworks
I mean code is an amazing tool but the
only thing we do with source code now is
we use it to represent things that are
already in the world but very much like
a realistic painting but we could have
other forms of good that I mean notice a
wine going from the glasses it wasn't
really interesting
like yeah you could have cubicles and
brutalist Code rokoko code we could
encode all these styles in code how
would it look like if you have the same
algorithm but the one is quantities and
the other one is surrealism what does it
even mean yeah more wine
anyway I managed to get this accepted as
a workshop at the booster conference
which is a very very nice conference
because I send in random proposals and
they're like that sounds fun it was five
lines of the garbage I was just saying
after the wine Oh God art they were like
yeah let's do it oh now I have to
do it so I did the workshop and it was
really very fun so the people that
participated in the workshop they said
ah this was really fun because I just
asked them these questions like write a
cubistic quick sort they have fun but I
wasn't really happy because they didn't
really create anything there was lots of
discussion people were doing things but
there wasn't pretty art that I could
sell to museum or anything and the
reason I think that that happened is one
of the things we did in the beginning of
the workshop I thought let's start easy
let's not go to visual arts immediately
let's start with doing some poems in
source code because poetry and code are
still relatively similar
so we first do a poem and then we can do
the paintings so the paintings never
happened because we totally got stuck on
the poems one of the exercises that you
need to do if you want to write a poem
for the right meter like if you have a
limerick it's always like toto so you
need to know the number of syllables in
a line of codes I thought about this but
I thought you know it's pretty easy
these are slides from the actual
workshop so we said are you for example
this line def burble sort a list it's
six syllables and I said well you know
sometimes maybe it can be confusing
because if you have an equal sign it
could be s or equals or becomes but just
pick one it doesn't really matter what
you do there big mistake
this are just pick one strategy didn't
work at all because we worked in groups
and the groups like oh sure we'll just
take this for assignments and then they
always like no works no that's
ridiculous it's not an es it's a it's an
equal sign and you don't say no no they
come up with new suggestions that
weren't even in my slide no it's stores
no its assigns to no it's set to so the
workshop was interesting as I said the
people were having fun debating how
keywords were be cold or how it would
sound they thought that exercise was fun
and useful like I'm gonna have a
painting but I learned a lot from this
because something I thought was trivial
just reading a line of source code
Aloud's turned into a new line of
research these things sometimes happen I
was like wow we have no clue how to
pronounce code as a community we just
haven't figured this out people have
opinions but we don't know this is
apparently not something we have decided
as a community so I read the entire
handbook of reading which is it's really
stretching the definition of a handbook
it has 500 words I have trouble holding
this in two hands but it's really very
interesting it's it makes you again
happy and sad at the same time because
if you read it you're like wow the
reading community has figured out how
stuff works they know everything from
every age level they know well if a kid
is 4 they read like this they speak like
that if they are 6 then this all the
stages have names and this happens like
whoa we programming we know nothing we
don't have any hypotheses or theories
about what happens in people's brains
when they're reading codes we could do
experiments like andreas did which is
great for the type of experiment you
wanted to do but if you want to do
something with with pronounciation we
lack the jury to even do an experiment
it's like makes you sad and happy at the
same time there's so much research into
reading you have this distinct phases
through which kids go if they're
learning to read so if you have a
five or six or seven-year-old hell at
home initially they're only focused on
the letter so they can't really read
worth or census it's the only thing they
can do is book and then they can read
words in at once so book in shelf cats
in tree but they're reading and I don't
really have a conception yet it's really
funny if you have kids of this age you
they can read like cats cats in treat so
where is the cats and they're like I
don't know they're reading but all their
mental energy is spent on the letters in
the word so they don't have energy left
to consider the meaning only after a
while we adult provisional readers we
can just say uh book is book it happens
immediately you don't spend any energy
anymore on reading and reading has
really figured all these levels out and
it's don't just for kids that sounds
really matter even if you're a
proficient reader of your own native
language still how something sounds is
very important to you so let's do an
experiment because I know it's like sick
so I once tired so another audience
participation moments we will do reading
sentences from the slide so it's very
easy I'll show you a sentence like this
there is a cat in the tree and if you
read it you raise your hands so you can
do it silently you don't have to do it
aloud if you've read it you raise your
hands we'll do a test first because
there's there's a tiny caveat I'll do it
in two steps so it's like there is a cat
in the tree and then you raise your
hands you want to do a practice round
everyone ready and I won't be speaking
it any more perfect here's another one
something happens in your brain right so
friendly how words sounds matter when
you're reading and this second sentence
if you try this with people this was in
the Oxford Handbook of reading people
are slower in these types of sentences
because some people have read there is a
tear and then in my pence that's
weird
oh it's there so you have to go back and
and it takes more time so even if you're
a proficient reader these type of
sentences take longer and they did
experiments also where the words changed
meaning but not sounds like the word
gaff
it can mean little cow but also part of
your leg so there were censuses like she
hurt her calf and then in the shed or in
the gym and the effect there was way
less than with these type of words so
it's not about that it changes meaning
it's about that it changed the sound
because you're sounding out the words in
your brain and there are people that
really want to do speed reading the
first thing they have to do is not sound
out the words this sounding out is
called sip vocalization and it takes
lots of energy apparently to suppress
the instincts or the practice we had in
subvocalization it's very hard to not do
it and this example I think nicely shows
that so when words sound ambiguously
comprehension suffers and then it maybe
leads to the question what about
keywords if keywords sound and
vigorously if it's really hard to know
how to sound something this
comprehension suffer it's likely that a
programming language is still a language
it's very likely that we to a certain
extent sound out vocalize code as well
but because we have no consistent model
maybe we could do it better if you would
practice that we asked thank it's these
are high school children to read out a
bunch of code snippets for us in a
systematic way so we told them you have
to do your programming homework but your
computer is broken so you're on the
phone with a friends and they're going
to type up your homework and a friend
knows programming so
you can assume that they sort of know
what it's about but they don't know what
they have to do so you have to tell them
we gave them exercise like this it's
equal signs five and they are all over
the place just like the professionals in
the first in the coding art workshop
equals five gets five sets to five
assign five 2x all over the place
they have no consistent story of how it
sounds like within another study where
we had 22 professional developers do the
same exercises as we presented with the
kids it was the exact same story all
over the place and we discussed the
answers with among the group so my idea
was there to reach some sort of
consensus that we could convince other
people that that pronunciation wasn't
the most logical that entirely failed
people were really cling to how they
thought it would be pronounced and the
interesting thing was that some people
even were inconsistent between code
snippets so in the one they said X and
what equals and the other one they said
x equals five they sometimes did weird
things with variable names we had a
variable temperature and some people
said the temperature is set to five but
they didn't do that of course with the
single letter variables it was
apparently a very very hard task just to
read code aloud and these ten novices in
the previous experiments for interesting
they were novices but they were also
Dutch so these are Dutch high school
children they're about 12 so they have
had two or three years of English
education they're definitely not
proficient in English and we didn't
think of that we just picked Dutch kids
because their clothes everywhere in the
Netherlands but the native thong really
plays a role in this code snippet so the
letter I if you would read it in English
is I I isn't Thai but if you read this
letter in Dutch we don't say I we say e
he isn't creep that's how we say this
letter we had kids mispronounce the
variable within one code snippet or
doing it in different ways so they set
things like for E in red
prints I in the same snippet they would
call the variable a different name and
we didn't do any measurements of their
cognition but it's very likely that if
they don't pronounce it in the same way
in their brain it hasn't clearly
registered that this is the same
variable and we observed the teachers
too and they were really inconsistent
sometimes when they were reading the
code usually when they were reading from
the security they would say things like
prints I because it makes sense because
prints isn't English words so you would
also say I in English way but then if
they were having conversations with kids
in Dutch I'll teach which variable do I
pick and then the teacher would say oh
it's e because normally we call the
letter e super confusing and we didn't
think about this natural language effect
at all which is weird because I myself
pronounce the word array as a lie until
I was in university because I got it
from a book and I didn't know how to say
it so I should have thought of hey it's
very hard to pronounce key words in
another who is Dutch in the audience in
another amazing example that will only
make sense to the Dutch people we had a
kid that pronounced while as Villa and
this makes sense he had an argument
ation even he said it makes sense
because villa in Dutch it means wheels
and it goes round like a loop perfect so
they don't know how to pronounce it and
they come up with their own imagination
of why a word means something is very
hard to correct because it was in his
brain it was we let it make sense so
what are you talking about with your
while
the conclusion here is we should tell
kids how to pronounce source code if we
want them to do it in a consistent way
likely freeing up mental space so you
should really if you're teaching new
things like repeat after me X is five
this is how you say it and even for
harder programming concepts like a loop
we should say for I in range this is how
the words sound especially for non
English kids but probably also for
English kids it's very helpful to know
how stuff sounds because then they can
supplies it and probably spend less
energy on reading the code practicing
this helps
we did a study again with Dutch kids
where half of the kids we got them and
lesson in which they were saying code
out loud all the time every week we
taught them a new syntax concept and we
said this is how you say it
it's really cool we said it as a group
for I in range from really nice exercise
and the other group is a control group
so they just got a random programming
less than a normal one in which we
didn't do any of those vocalization
exercises and the first group did better
on syntax questions than the second
group and if I would present this work
to elementary school teachers or high
school teachers they would be like yeah
of course seeing stuff allowed is how
you make kids remember things like the
tables of multiplication most people
that learn the tables of multiplication
in school it's like two times three is
six until it's really in your brain this
isn't rocket science but as I was
referring to in the beginning because we
don't have this collective memory of how
a programming lesson looks like the
basic things like if you want kids to
remember stuff you make them sound it
out it's just not in our collective
memory but of course if we want to have
what I call a code phonology a way of
pronouncing code if we want to do this
for kids we have to agree on how the
things are called that's going to be the
hardest parts so my proposal to
programming language designers is that
with their syntax they will say how the
key words are cold put it in your
language specification I don't care
about what you pick other people will I
don't I just want to have an answer for
how everything sounds like so we can use
it in education and it's probably going
to be very very hard to get people to
this point but it's really important
that this is that there's a system on
how to do it and I think the impact of
this is going to be way bigger than just
education as I said it's going to be
really cool for lessons if we if I say
in a classroom egg's gets five and I
know that the kids are thinking of the
right programming concepts that's going
to be super powerful in teaching but
there are lots of other ways in which
this is going to help
for example pair programming if you
don't pair programming
and even remote pair programming you're
like ah type your brackets huh records
no I mean in round brackets this is
conversations people have apparently if
you're pairing with someone that is not
a native programmer in that language and
doesn't know where the brackets go in
Java but also again this has to do with
people that use English as their second
language I don't know how you pull all
the symbols you don't know how you call
the symbols is it a pound is it a hash
tag English we have good words for this
so it's very confusing and all the
energy that's that that we spend on yeah
but what symbol Oh a double equal a
single equals a triple equals is all not
going into making programs so if you
just figure this out it will be super
useful and there's one other group that
I care about actually a lot that could
definitely benefit from a good way of
speaking code and that's people that are
blind or visually impaired the way the
people that are blind or visually
impaired process text any text is with a
screen reader so it just reads the text
and they're pretty good they're free
ones and open-source ones these are the
things people use but those things are
made for natural language because there
aren't that many blind programmers so if
you read something like this if we read
it like this deafened the score
underscore in it and the score in the
score which is terrible and this isn't
even the worst example it gets worse
because if you have something like this
it will read out Harry and then a pause
because it's adults and then name this
is how screen readers read because
normally if you're reading normal text
you don't want to say bolts here dots at
the ends you want to hear a pause and
it's very hard to calibrate them to be
able to read source code so if we would
just figure out the phonology we could
put that understanding into these type
of programs and then people that are
blind could also conveniently read
source code rather than do it in a very
annoying way and the opposite might be
true as well people that don't have
control of their arms anymore they could
speak the source code because we have a
consistent understanding and then that
might make their lives easier
that's it that's everything I wanted to
share allow me to summarize my entire
talk in my let's say 30 seconds there
isn't any room for Q&A because we have
to leave this room because this is where
pop Kampf is going to be and I was told
to ask you to all go out of the room so
they can prep it and change it into a
real pub and then come back so we're not
going to do Q&A but I will be a pop
Kampf as well so if you want to ask me
questions you can totally do it after my
summary or tomorrow as well
my talk was about how does code sounds
which is interesting because we don't
really have a good conception of what
programming is and what programming
education is mainly because we hang out
in programming and with programmers all
the time so we don't really know how it
works
secondly if you just take one thing from
this talk don't be those people don't be
those people it's terrible if a V B 6
programmer comes to your meetup like
hello I'm new here what do you program
vb6 you'll say welcome sir this great
come and tell me about your beautiful
language don't tell them it's not a real
programming language if people say
they're programming their programming
what we know from how people perceive
natural language is that it really
matters how words are sounding because
you're so focusing your brain and it's a
trick that's very very hard to diminish
so it's very likely that if you're
reading source code you also to a
certain extent soup focalize so it
really matters how our keywords sounds
if we ask people both novices but also
professionals to read code aloud they do
it in a non systematic norm consistent
way so this is not a solved problem an
extra complication happens when people
don't speak English as a first language
and they confuse the pronunciation of
key words because they alternate between
a natural native language and English we
tried it and it turns out it actually
helps even though of course it was a
small first study but it actually helps
if you teach kids how things sound if
you practice it then they will remember
better
so go back home tell your favorite
language designer to get their
together and give us a phonology I don't
care what you pick but just pick one so
we can use it in education and as I said
potentially also in tools for the blind
in tools for pair programming and tools
for people that cannot use their hands
anymore
that's it I will ask answer a few
questions that I always answer if you
want to know more about my research you
can go to my website where our video is
for all my talks and my research I'm on
Twitter as well I made these slides with
an app called good notes yes I did throw
it on my hands on my iPads and if you
want to listen to me more because you
enjoyed this dog I'm also a host of the
Essie radio podcast if you're like I
would like to hear more from Felina
that's a good way to learn more about me
and the guests that we interview on the
show and thanks to a bunch of people
that are amazing the ends
[Applause]